on dirait que c'est une terme sur tout à
fait toujours le même c'est l'instant
pas caché qu'un koala on a tous fait la
star non si on dit par exemple genre
ouais il manque sa la table régis jean
pourquoi n'y a pas de chocolat noir avec
des éclats de caramel de dans la du coup
ça ne vient pas trop tard les deux c'est
tout se répète brême brême il a pédalé
c'est vrai qu'une bêta l'air et la
marine vélo city se retrouve dans la
merde tout le temps ce qui bat
[Musique]
sémantique il arrive 45 minutes à une
heure si c'est pas franchement je dirais
moi moi je suis plus reiss est en fait
c'est pas qu'on n'aime pas c'est que
c'est pas varié on a chez mamie cheb
khaled cheb ouais j'ai bouffé bref
chaque chaîne
les deux attaques mais deux matches non
les deux il a une carrière à gérer donc
il est obligé de mettre les deux pas
monté près c'est juste que j'ai
république est extrêmement nombreux que
je dois contenter jean marc robichaud
avec des stars j'en profite
[Musique]